[Music]
breaking news this thursday night a
major break in a decade's old
cold case the man who murdered a toronto
girl in 1984.
i'm here because of the diligent work of
toronto police investigators
the new technology that identified the
killer and why
he won't be brought to justice pushing
for peace
if we don't get this right is that
people will die mounting pressure to
resolve nova scotia's lobster fishing
feud the rcmp they're useless
alarming new increases in covig-19 cases
where infections were once
low the mission to control the spread
campaigning
in the time of covid our jackson prosco
is in north carolina tonight
and when your vacation plans go south
covet came which changed our plans
completely
this year's holiday haven for snowbirds
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with the murder of a little
girl that has gone unsold for 36 years
today toronto police say they have
finally cracked the case of christine
jessup
who was killed in 1984. she was nine
years old when she went missing in
queensville ontario a small town north
of toronto
police say she had plans to meet a
friend at a nearby park after school
that day but never showed up
she took the school bus home dropped off
her bag and vanished
the case haunted her family and the
community a neighbor was wrongly
convicted exonerated by dna testing
today this man was named as jesup's
killer calvin hoover who was
28 at the time and known to the family
police say new dna technology linked him
to the case
it's genetic genealogy that we've
actually used genetic genealogy is a
very useful tool
in murder investigations such as this
one it is not a dna match
what it is is it provides a potential
and i must stress
a potential family lineage
from a dna sample in our top story
tonight eric sorenson explains how the
cold case
was cracked what it means for the jessup
family and why the killer
will never be charged it's an
announcement few thought they would ever
hear
calvin hoover of toronto ontario was 28
years old in 1984.
a name finally for the killer of
nine-year-old christine jessop who
disappeared this month
36 years ago the man identified calvin
hoover was an acquaintance of
christine's parents
this is not a reason to celebrate it
does however allow us to take a major
step forward in our efforts to bring
justice
to christine's family hoover died by
suicide
five years ago police say they tracked
him down with dna
using a police only data bank in the
united states
that identified two family trees the
name calvin hoover
is one of the names that came up in two
specific families that we saw
built out the name calvin hoover
upon review of the investigative file
is a name that we know had a
connection to the jessup family there
was no trace of christine when she
disappeared her body found weeks later
50 kilometers from her home in
queensville north of toronto
she'd been raped and stabbed multiple
times
months later police charged jessop's
next-door neighbor 24-year-old gee paul
morin with murder
setting off legal battles that would
last a decade morin was first acquitted
of the crime
but in a second trial in 1992 was found
guilty and went to prison
then dna technology still in its infancy
cleared him and finally as i said dna
has exonerated me
100 percent the case roiled the ontario
justice system and left the jesup family
lost the trail of the killer had long
since gone cold
her brother ken jesse christine is still
dead
and there is still no person
no longer accused now a quarter century
later ken jessup spoke with global news
now that calvin hoover has been
identified disbelief
i was stunned it's a wonderful day for
justice and at least
he saved us the hardship of going
through another trial
this from gee paul morin who was
wrongfully convicted
christine's murder was a terrible and
tragic event when dna exonerated me in
1995 i was sure one day
dna would reveal the real killer and now
it has
this is one of those cases where science
has won out over the justice system
more than 30 years after her daughter
died janet jessup told global news
what she had wanted most where is he
that's the question i have
i want to find him him her it whomever
and that's my goal finally it seems that
goal has been reached
eric you first covered christine
jessup's case when she disappeared more
than 30 years ago
now police have identified her killer
but he's dead
so it's an ending but is it justice
well it's just us a long time in coming
but it is still justice to finally solve
a crime i mean that is the ultimate goal
whenever there's a tragedy like this
i think there's huge relief for the
police because they went down the wrong
path after the wrong person
at the time there's relief for the
justice system because of the wrongful
conviction
and i think for the family there has to
be a sense of closure now because really
the jessups year after year were just
wanting answers and they couldn't get
the right answer and looks
like now they finally do have an answer
as tragic as
as it ultimately is and so eric is the
case now closed
no it's not closed calvin hoover was
known to police because he was part of a
wide investigation at the time he was a
friend or at least an acquaintance of
the family so they knew of him
but he was not a suspect at the time now
they're looking for the public's help in
filling in the holes between 1984 when
christine disappeared and died and 2015
when hoover
uh died and so they've got a lot of
years to fill in the pieces to try and
figure out
what he did during all that time all
right eric sorenson in toronto thanks
now to nova scotia and the violence over
the lobster catch
indigenous fishers are pushing ahead
with their self-regulated lobster
fishery and threaten legal action
against those who stand in the way
at the heart of the issue are the rights
of indigenous lobster harvesters to fish
outside the commercial season rights
protected by the marshall decision a
supreme court of canada ruling
indigenous leaders are demanding the
federal government enforce the law
here's what the indigenous services
minister said today
these unacceptable acts of violence
including the assault of chief sack
threats and intimidation some racist in
nature
cannot and will not fetter the right of
the mi'kmaq people to pursue
a moderate livelihood as affirmed close
to 25 years ago
in the marshall decision but talk
is not leading to any resolution on the
docks in nova scotia
as ross lord reports indigenous fishers
guard a driveway to a lobster holding
pound
as police screen nearby traffic to rule
out potential troublemakers
bitterness simmers from tuesday night
when an angry group of commercial
fishers
threatened an indigenous harvester
attacking property and removing his
lobsters
in full view of the rcmp look at them i
know
what do you mean you know the chief of
the sebago naggity first nation suggests
his members are going alone very
concerned for all of our people
you know to safety and it's come to the
point where it's a matter of
do our lives matter chief sack himself
had a physical altercation with another
man
zach says he'll pursue assault charges
and possibly
legal action against organizations
assigned to protect his people
from what he calls racist violence the
rcmp
they're useless he sent a letter to the
prime minister
urging him to ensure the safety of
indigenous fishers the rcmp
defends its handling of the violent
protests our goal is
is for everyone to go home that that
night
and in this case we feel we're fortunate
in the case that everybody did
there was no injuries involved in either
of these here incidents
nova scotia premier stephen mcneil says
he's disappointed the federal government
has failed to defuse
tensions the government has held a
series of meetings
some with first nations leaders others
with commercial harvesters
even though the fisheries minister has
kept a low profile
yesterday's actions unfortunately they
were they're they're
uncalled for and extremely
disappointing and
disgusting for lack of a better word and
unfortunately those
those actions could be stalling the
negotiations that we were
making very good progress on the
indigenous services minister while
acknowledging systemic racism in
policing is clear
about what's at stake the risk if we
don't get this right is that people will
die
and i think everyone should be clear
about what that means
because violence begets violence
untangling tensions has been just as
confounding
as it was when the supreme court upheld
indigenous fishing rights
more than 20 years ago ross lord global
news
halifax now to another crisis beginning
to spread through indigenous communities
across canada
they were largely shielded from covid 19
in the spring but
reserves are now reporting the highest
number of active cases since the start
of the pandemic
michael couture reports on what's
driving the spread and what's being done
to try to contain it from the outside
it's a nondescript building in prince
albert saskatchewan
but a service inside the full gospel
outreach center is being linked
to at least 25 cases of covid19
many in attendance were from surrounding
first nations communities
and it's helped to push the total case
count in indigenous communities
to 209 i think the highest that we've
seen it
to date at any at any date and so it's
very alarming
especially because of how well
indigenous communities fared during the
first
wave but now the curve is bending up
the biggest concern is how the virus can
spread quickly
in multi-generational homes and the
fragility
of the health care system in the north
you know if montreal can get overwhelmed
the health care system in much you all
can get overwhelmed certainly a small
remote community fly-in access
can easily get overwhelmed as well it's
why a chief of a first nation in
northern saskatchewan ordered a lockdown
of her community
after a spike in covid 19 cases we have
a high population of elders in our
communities
those with compromised immune systems
so we're we're really concerned because
it's a serious health threat
an even bigger threat according to
indigenous services minister mark miller
is the lack of trust indigenous
communities have
in the health care system especially
after the world saw what happened to
joyce echaquan
in a quebec hospital it's why he's
convening a meeting on friday with the
minister of crown indigenous relations
and first nations leaders to start the
process
of eliminating systemic racism in
canada's health system
donna all right mike lucatour thank you
in manitoba the spread of covet 19 is
becoming alarming 173 new cases were
reported today that's a record number in
manitoba
the province's top doctor says
widespread restrictions on gathering and
other tough rules could be imposed in
winnipeg as early as tomorrow
dr brent russon says people have been
asked to reduce their contacts and stay
home if they're sick but it's clear
some people are not listening we can see
we've lost
we've lost our way with the fundamentals
at this point
so we're going to need to act to be able
to bring down these numbers
today's case count in manitoba is the
third day of record high numbers
there in saskatchewan there are 33 new
cases today further west alberta has 244
b.c more than 140 and big numbers again
today in quebec
969 new cases there and in ontario
783 there's an update tonight on the
outbreak at spinco fitness studio in
hamilton ontario at least 72 cases are
now linked to the cycling studio after
three more people tested positive public
health officials have said
they are reviewing rules for fitness
studios
the coronavirus and vying for votes
coming up
we're in north carolina where the
pandemic has become an election
flashpoint
to the american presidential campaign
now joe biden's running mate kamala
harris has suspended her campaign events
and travel until monday
because her communications director and
a flight crew member have tested
positive for covet 19. harris was on a
flight with both those people the day
after the vice presidential debate with
mike pence though the campaign says she
was not in close contact with them
and if lineups for early voting are any
indication thousands of americans seem
highly motivated to cast their ballot
in north carolina where early voting
started today
people waited for hours in long lines
and as they wait coveted case numbers
keep rising
in north carolina more than 2500 new
cases were reported just today
and yet president trump keeps telling
people not to worry
jackson proskow reports
another day another tightly packed trump
rally
in another state where kovitt 19 cases
are surging
tell your governor open up your state
open up your schools
despite the rise in cases here and
across the country
the president told the crowd of mostly
masculist supporters
that the pandemic would soon be over my
plan is already crushing the virus
trump many trump voters were already
convinced that the virus is no big deal
are you worried at all about your safety
being here today packed together in a
crowd
no not at all not at all will you wear a
mask no
i think that there's a lot of other more
pressing issues than the pandemic
some have embraced trump's falsehoods
and the grim u.s death toll
and claim it's a tale of success we are
behind him 100 the u.s is doing more
than your gov
your canadian gov you know uh population
uh the european population the us is is
doing better than anyone around the
world right now
north carolina population 10 million has
recorded more cases than all of canada
today the unemployment rate sits at 8.5
percent
this has been beyond embarrassing to
friends
around the world and even around the
country
to see the the lack of leadership to joe
biden's supporters
trump's record is one of historic
failure brewery owner celeste beatty has
seen business drop off by
70 percent she was hoping for another
government relief package
until trump called off the talks to have
you know the president saying well we're
just going to hold back into after the
election that was very insulting and
just so inhumane
to have him play around with people's
lives like that when there's such a
great need
four years ago trump easily won north
carolina
today polls suggest this critical swing
state could go either way
the pandemic threatens donald trump's
chances at a second term
but hasn't cost him the support of his
ever loyal base
we're the only true one that is telling
the truth
yes and is going to save us all
if undecided voters were hoping for any
sort of clarity in these final days of
the campaign
they likely won't be getting it tonight
what was supposed to have been a
presidential debate has been replaced
with two separate and simultaneous town
halls
featuring trump and joe biden different
channels at the same time
that means that partisan supporters are
likely to bubble themselves with the
candidate of their choice
and not see the opposing candidates
views expressed in any way if they don't
want to hear them
donna jackson proskow in north carolina
thanks
strict new restrictions in england still
ahead why not everyone
is on board
queen elizabeth is back in action this
was her first official engagement in
seven months she went to porter down
military research facility with her
grandson prince william
all of them kept far apart though none
wore masks
since march the 94 year old has been
meeting people virtually from windsor
castle
she was with a small team of dedicated
staff today known as
hms bubble who have been isolating with
her
at the palace kovit 19 cases across
europe are surging at an alarming rate
and today the world health
organization's director for europe said
the region is seeing a significant rise
in hospital admissions and deaths and an
exponential increase
in daily cases the region has registered
the highest weekly incidence of covet 19
cases
since the beginning of the pandemic with
almost
700 000 cases reported
confirmed cases have now surpassed
7 million moving from six
to seven million cases in just ten days
several countries including the uk are
reimposing limits on gatherings they
hope will stop the spread of the virus
as crystal gamating explains in england
more regions are now under controversial
restrictions
we have to protect ourselves and protect
everybody else i think it's a waste of
time lock
the whole place down look the whole
country down in a city of roughly
9 million reaction is mixed to london
moving to the second tier or
high level of england's three-tier alert
system
the mayor says with infections nearing
100 cases per 100 000 individuals
action is needed more patients are going
to intensive care units
and sadly the number of londoners dying
every day
is increasing again the escalation
bans people from different households
from meeting up in any indoor
setting liverpool city region is
currently the only location in
england at very high tier 3 restrictions
the mayor of greater manchester refuses
a push from the national government
to move the alert to very high and shut
down pubs
gyms and casinos to do so
will result in certain hardship job
losses
business failure it will cause harm in a
different way
to people's mental health and is not
certain to
control the virus the british health
secretary says the north west
and northeast have the highest infection
rates
this is a time for people to come
together so that we can control
this virus discussions over financial
compensation for greater manchester
are ongoing but even if an agreement
isn't reached
the british government could impose the
new alert level on the community
crystal gamansen global news london
weathering the pandemic next where
canada's snowbirds are flocking
this is the time lots of canadians go
south to escape the winter
the pandemic has thrown a wrench into
their plan so some snowbirds are heading
to the warmest spots they can find
within canada
as robin gill explains
peter fairhead staked out a spot at this
rv
park before it got busy normally the
alberta man would be heading to
arizona or california not this year
i would take this kind of weather over
cool
or a foot or two feet of snow
i don't have to shovel the rain the 2020
road map for canada snowbirds
head west we should go to the beach
later karen and kirby stevens live year
round in their rv
the summers are spent in victoria the
winters in florida
we're going to stay until april 1st but
then
covid came which changed our plans
completely
they're finding themselves in the same
boat or in their case
the same rv as other snowbirds now as
far as they're concerned
british columbia is as close to sandal
weather as they're going to get
we'll get there eventually but just
go with the flow so to speak rv parks
and campgrounds in bc have the advantage
of being open
year-round but good luck getting a
reservation this year we filled up
in august rather than october we're
seeing
a huge increase in inquiries of people
from across the country
in ontario sandy monroe is catching a
last round of golf
he'll head to florida in the new year
even though he's taking a chance
the warmth and the sun and the blue sky
is more important than
freezing to death here in the winter
okay bud the stevens family sees their
own patches of blue
if you have to be somewhere in canada
victoria's i
have no doubt that that's why the island
is so full
back on bc's mainland peter fairhead is
making himself
right at home in his rv community and
has no regrets cancelling the american
adventure
the situation just is a little unnerving
south of the border so it's just you
know
we're here it seems his feathered
friends feel the same way
because they don't appear to be heading
south either
robin gill global news vancouver
and that is global national for this
thursday i'm donna friesen keeping it in
bc tonight's your canada is ec
manning provincial park in southern bc
thanks for watching
take care of yourselves bye-bye
you